ceci est un smartphone avec une très
grosse autonomie à 379 euros par les
smartphones à moins de 400 balles ça
c'est chouette parce que c'est le Honor
Magic 5 Lite regardez vous avez la boîte
qui est juste ici et surtout c'est le
premier smartphone de Honor qui arrive
ici en Europe en France en 2023 et
surtout et bien c'est le petit modèle de
la gamme au nord Magic 5 au nord Magic 5
on en reparlera très bientôt avec le
professionnel qui va être présenté au
MWC je vous emmène avec moi donc pensez
à vous abonner cliquez sur le bouton
rouge et actionner la cloche comme ça
vous saurez tout mais aujourd'hui on se
fait un gros focus sur ce Honor Magic 5
Lite et ça c'est chouette moi je suis
prêt vous êtes prêt allez on y va
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec Honor aux
normes a dit tiens mon beau monsieur Gru
est-ce que tu voudrais pas venir nous
présenter le Magic 5 Lite qui est le
tout premier smartphone qu'on vient
sortir dans la gamme Magic 5 qui arrive
dans la gamme Magic 5 Magic Mike est
hyper dur à dire Magic 5 qui arrive ici
en France aujourd'hui qu'un smartphone
qui coule en fait qui est cool pourquoi
parce qu'il fait vraiment cette promesse
cette promesse cette promesse elle est
tenue et bien c'est la très grosse aut
un tarif très maîtrisé donc il y a plein
de choses à venir raconter sur ce
smartphone je sais pas si vous
connaissez au nord on a déjà beaucoup
parlé au nord regardez alors là je vous
demande vite fait parce que chez Honor
il y a plein de produits ma chaise
tourne rien ne va plus il
y a un vidéo pour vous parler de
l'écosystème du Honor et je vous dis
pourquoi c'est intéressant d'aller
là-bas parce qu'en fait vos smartphones
de Honor ils vont venir communiquer avec
votre ordinateur de Honor vous allez
pouvoir mettre directement l'écran de
votre ordinateur sur votre smartphone
alors l'idée c'est pas le regarder c'est
beau sapin non l'idée c'est que vous
allez pouvoir lorsque vous bossez sur
votre ordi et bien répondre à vos SMS
directement depuis votre ordinateur vous
allez pouvoir directement faire du
glisser déposer des photos du
copier-coller il y a plein d'usages
assez très chouette et tout ça s'inscrit
dans un écosystème alors je vous le
montrer rapidement mais la vidéo est
déjà sur ma chaîne elle est jeter un
coup d'oeil chez Honor il y a le Honor
70 sur tes dernières qui est très bien
vous avez la Watch GS3 il y a également
de la tablette avec la Honor pas 8
également des écouteurs avec les Honor
herbeuzz 3 pro voilà c'est ça mais c'est
pas le sujet du jour non le sujet du
jour mes petits lapins et bien c'est de
se parler de celui-là le Honor Magic 5
Lite parce que moi ce que je trouve avec
ce smartphone je vous le dis francier
c'est que il est tout fin et ça ça me
plaît bien d'avoir un smartphone tout
fin dans la main alors ça dépend une
fois de plus un des goûts des couleurs
de ce qu'on veut si on veut un
smartphone un peu plus cher fatalement
ou sur du premium on aura plus de choses
à l'intérieur il sera plus plus épais
probablement un peu plus lourd également
là ici ça reste maîtrisé il pèse 175 g
et fait 7,9 mm d'épaisseur et il y a
vraiment cette sensation en main donc si
vous voulez un smartphone qui se tient
bien en main ça c'est très chouette vous
avez quand même un écran de 6,67 pouces
c'est très bien pour venir regarder du
contenu multimédia tu as pris fatalement
quand vous avez un écran de 667 pouces
vous aurez un smartphone un peu plus
grand et donc on va venir utiliser à
demain lorsque vous venez en bon voilà
il faut le savoir c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les écrans des
smartphones sont de plus en plus grands
donc fatalement la prise en main va être
un peu plus grande après le truc qui est
cool que j'aime bien aussi sur ce
smartphone c'est que votre écran il est
légèrement incurvé il est d'ailleurs
incurvé à 45 degrés alors on va pas
venir ici mesurer les angles mais ce que
j'aime bien dans ce côté incurvé alors
tout le monde n'aime pas les écrans
curve il y en a qui aiment bien les
écrans plats mais moi ce que je mets
dans les écrans incurvés c'est que ça
vous permet d'avoir un côté un peu plus
immersif et je trouve ça assez joli donc
au nord a quand même vachement bien
bossé là-dessus ils ont faim notre truc
c'est que la crainte souvent qu'on a des
écrans incurvés c'est que lorsque vous
allez venir passer votre main sur
l'écran sur le côté et bien vous allez
faire des actions que vous ne souhaitez
pas faire ou lorsque vous le tenez comme
ça avec le côté de votre main et bien
regardez là ils ont fait un truc spécial
ce qui fait que ça va pas déconner sur
le côté forcément si je me mets là tout
va bien je suis sur l'écran mais si je
me rapproche fatalement un moment ça va
venir marcher je vais venir bouger ici
mais si je suis juste là sur le côté ça
va donc en fait ça vient éviter que en
le tenant comme ça avec la paume de ma
main sur le côté et bien je viens de
faire des actions donc ça c'est chouette
c'est bien vu et bien pensé l'autre truc
qui est cool avec cet écran c'est que
c'est un écran OLED oui ça c'est bien
alors ça veut dire quoi un écran OLED ça
veut dire que lorsque vous avez une
partie qui est noire sur votre écran et
bien c'est un pixel éteindre donc ça
vient pas consommer en terme d'énergie
donc ça c'est vraiment bien l'autre truc
c'est que lorsque vous vous mettez sur
un thème sombre vous allez retrouver hop
là ici vous passez en thème sombre et
bien tout ce qui est noir est éteint
donc on vient économiser par rapport à
un écran LCD qui va fabriquer du noir
mais qui en fait ça sera pas un pixel
éteint donc ça viendra consommer donc ça
c'est très très chouette on se parle en
plus ici d'un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement dynamique on va monter
jusqu'à 120 Hertz alors vous avez
différents modes soit vous mettez en
dynamique ce que je vous recommande
franchement c'est à dire que il va venir
monter jusqu'à un max de 120 Hertz alors
sans rien vous en aurez plus besoin
lorsque vous allez arriver par exemple
sur un Instagram et que vous allez venir
voyez scroller comme ça à fond à fond
bah là vous allez monter en sangria ça
va être beaucoup mieux pour vos yeux
lorsque vous allez venir jouer à des
jeux donc ça c'est très chouette pour le
gaming on peut également venir jouer je
vais vous expliquer dans quelques
instants donc tout ce côté là il est
vachement cool et une fois de plus vous
allez venir le retrouver ici alors après
il existe d'autres modes vous allez
avoir le mode élevé qui va venir pousser
à fond je vous le conseille pas parce
que ça va venir taper dans la batterie
de votre smartphone ou alors le mode
standard qui vous laisse en gros à 60
donc là en gros vous êtes à 120 là à 60
et là vous laissez faire la module entre
120 60 90 il va venir faire son truc
tout seul autre petit détail à venir
connaitre ici qui est très malin c'est
que vous avez une résolution
intelligente donc là vous êtes en Full
HD et vous pouvez lui dire ben écoute
débrouille-toi tu vas me gérer la
résolution c'est toi qui va voir comme
ça ça permet d'économiser aussi un petit
peu au niveau de la batterie c'est
plutôt bien puis vous avez différents
modes qui sont assez bien vu également
le mode confort des yeux hop là vous
pouvez soit programmer en vous disant
ben moi je mets le soir ou alors je le
mets en permanence et si je le mets en
permanence là je vais mettre le niveau
du filtre bon moi personnellement le
mode confort des yeux c'est pas un truc
que j'aime trop parce que il y a un côté
un peu jaune même s'ils sont venus
bosser dessus malgré tout on le retrouve
quand même c'est bien de le mettre plus
pour le soir si vous voulez le
programmer que vous avez une petite
lumière douce à côté de vous ça quand
même mieux personnellement je le
désactive après vous avez un autre mode
qui est pas mal c'est le mode ebook
lorsque vous voulez venir lire et bien
ça va enlever les couleurs ça va
permettre d'avoir beaucoup plus reposant
pour vos yeux donc ça c'est aussi
vachement bien ce mode là je préfère en
fait allemand vraiment pour venir
également prérégler la modé à
température des couleurs soit vive soit
normal alors j'aime bien le vif parce
que vous avez un blanc très blanc et
c'est très pétant j'aime bien aussi
normal je trouve plus reposant pour les
yeux c'est un peu moins saturé un peu
moins pétant il y a un côté un peu plus
jaune donc en fait moi ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est que lorsque
vous voulez avoir un truc un peu plus
tranquille pour vos yeux au lieu de
mettre le confort des yeux et bien vous
venez hop là ici et vous passez aux
couleurs normal c'est beaucoup plus doux
c'est sympa et ça marchera très très
bien donc voilà ça petit petit truc à
faire mais je trouve ça assez malin au
nord nous dit ici c'est pas un Corning
Gorillaz ok par contre ils nous disent
on est vraiment venus travailler sur la
solidité de notre appareil ils nous
disent qu'il est renforcé en profondeur
à 0,65 mm alors nous avons montré des
tas de vidéos où on venait prendre son
smartphone et on le taper très fort on
éclatait une pastèque avec une voiture
roulé dessus j'ai pas envie de faire la
démo je veux bien les croire de ce que
j'ai vu aux images ça avait l'air d'être
bien donc il y a un côté rassurant pour
autant ne prenez pas vos smartphones et
n'ouvrez pas l'ananas avec on va quand
même méditer la déconvenue parce que si
toutefois il y avait le moins de
problèmes au la garantie il vous dirait
non non vous avez avec la tas d'ananas
avec donc on le fait pas ce qui est très
cool aussi c'est ce qu'on va voir à
l'arrière alors au Nord avait déjà fait
ça une année avec la série Magic 4 et il
vient de continuer ici avec un côté très
symétrique au niveau de son design on
vient le voir notamment ici au niveau de
la partie photo ils ont vraiment voulu
jouer toute la partie symétrie avec les
différents capteurs vous allez avoir
trois capteurs photos que vous avez là
et puis la partie avec le flash LED donc
ça je trouve ça assez joli vous le mette
en fait c'est le design matrix star qui
veut vraiment jouer sur la symétrie
alors là il y a trois couleurs moi la
couleur que j'ai c'est le titanium
Silver et le titanium silver il est très
joli parce que vous avez différents
reflets un peu plus rouge en bas un peu
plus jaune au milieu et un peu plus bleu
sur l'eau j'aime beaucoup ce côté là je
trouve très jolie elle existe également
d'autres couleurs vous avez le vert
émeraude et Brad Green et vous avez le
Midnight Black le noir voilà je pense
que tout le monde dirait un peu surnom
mais moi cette couleur je vous la
recommande parce que je la trouve très
jolie très élégante et elle prend pas
les traces de doigts donc ça c'est très
très chouette donc ça c'est un
smartphone qui reste un tarif une fois
de plus très maîtrisé 379 euros et à 379
euros et bien vous avez un smartphone
qui saura pas tout faire par contre ce
qui va faire c'est qu'il va pas être
mauvais au niveau de la performance vous
avez le Snapdragon 6 15 c'est un
processeur 5G qu'on connaît déjà qui est
déjà sorti il y a un petit moment mais
qui est un bon processeur et qui ira
très bien qui vous permettra de venir
jouer à beaucoup de jeux du Play Store
alors pour autant vous avez pas mettre
les jeux les plus gourmands pour autant
vous allez pas me faire tous les trucs
avec les résolutions maximales mais vous
allez faire tourner beaucoup de jeux
sans aucun problème donc si vous voulez
avoir un smartphone assez polyvalent
pour venir vous amuser avec et bien
c'est très chouette vous avez en plus
ici 6 gigas de RAM alors il y a une
techno que nous a mis au nord dans ce
smartphone regardez vous avez le rame
turbo en fait ça veut dire que vous avez
6 Go de RAM et qu'on vient en plus vous
rajoutez 5 giga de ram au Nord-Am turbo
en fait ça fait quoi sur un turbo vous
avez vos 6 gigas de RAM c'est de la RAM
classique de la RAM et votre stockage
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rhum et en
fait ce que ça va faire c'est que ça va
venir prendre au niveau de votre
stockage pour vous créer de la rame
virtuelle jusqu'à 5 Go de RAM virtuelle
donc vous avez 6 + 5 vous montez à 11
bravo je suis fort en maths merci à vous
de m'avoir soutenu là-dessus ça va
permettre de fluidifier un peu tout ça
notamment au niveau des tâches faites
par les applications en arrière-plan
enfin ça va fluidifier un peu
l'expérience avec votre smartphone donc
ça c'est bien dans sa chambre vous avez
128 Go de stockage ici mais là où le
smartphone est super intéressant c'est
que vous avez à l'intérieur une très
grosse batterie de 5100 milliampères
heure c'est quand même plutôt fatal 5100
millions par heure Eléonore m'a dit que
5 Lite a jusqu'à 3 jours d'autonomie ça
c'est dxcellente autonomie au front 3
jours d'usage en utilisation modérée et
ça lui donne ici un top score en
batterie 152 et vous voyez qu'il est au
maximum de ce qu'on peut retrouver ici
chez DX en Marc et qu'on a à peu près 30
minutes de charge vous récupérez 12
heures et 30 minutes de lecture de vidéo
sur Youtube parce qu'ici vous avez de la
recharge 40 watts alors bon la recherche
avant toi c'est cool mais comme beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'ils font et bien vous avez
la recherche 40 watts mais vous n'avez
pas de bloc de charge inclus j'ai Hugo
fouillé j'ai regardé tous les côtés il y
a pas de bloc de charge au nord c'est
comme beaucoup de constructeurs
aujourd'hui comment s'enlever un peu les
blocs de charge donc si vous voulez
venir avoir un bloc de charge rapide 40
watts et bien il faut venir l'acheter
dans le commerce pour trouver un bloc de
charge compatible avec votre Honor Magic
5 Lite et si on aura fait le choix de
pas mettre de chargeur c'est dans le
cadre d'une politique plus verte de la
marque et plus écologique et ça c'est
cool par contre il allonge une
durabilité jusqu'à trois ans c'est à
dire que votre smartphone la batterie ne
va pas se dégrader pendant trois ans
alors vous le savez plus on va mettre de
cycle de charge plus la batterie va
potentiellement moins venir se dégrader
c'est comme une espèce d'éponge en fait
qu'il faut venir imaginer pour la
batterie de votre smartphone et bien
plus vous utilisez les ponts je vous
rendez compte qu'à un moment les ponts
j'avais plus en faire et bien si c'est
un peu la même chose plus vous allez lui
mettre des sites des sites des cycles un
moment et ben il y a des cellules qui
vont commencer à plus fonctionner mais
c'est normal au nord vous annonce que
vous gardez une capacité à 80% après
1000 cycles de recharge donc trois ans
de durée de vie au niveau de l'autonomie
de votre smartphone et comme en plus il
est très endurant et bien vous allez
l'emmener loin et ça c'est chouette ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait
vous avez pas besoin de vous poser la
question d'avoir votre bloc de charge
avec vous alors il y a un moment il le
faut il faut le recharger bien
évidemment 5100 milliards par heure faut
lui mettre un peu de charges pour autant
s'il est chargé vous savez vous êtes
tranquille pendant au moins deux jours
vous allez donc pas stressé à vous dire
mince mince il faut que je le recharcher
ça alors bien évidemment si vous êtes
des hardcore gamer sur ce smartphone je
suis pas convaincu mais si vous jouez
énormément sur ce smartphone et que vous
passez beaucoup de temps à regarder des
vidéos beaucoup de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux l'autonomie elle sera moindre
fatalement ça va dépendre une fois de
plus de vous et de vos usages mais pour
un usage équilibré un peu monsieur et
madame tout le monde deux jours on peut
y aller on est tranquille et ça c'est
vachement bien alors maintenant il y a
un autre truc c'est toute la partie
photo alors regardez je vous le montre
la plus bref un point 8 ok vous avez un
ultra grand-angle qui est planqué là de
5 mégapixels qui ouvrait F 2.2 et puis
vous avez de la macro de 2 mégapixels
que vous voyez 2.4 sans oublier une
caméra de selfie regardez là je viens
déverrouiller avec mon capteur
d'empreinte digitale je pose mon doigt
ça dérange bien hop là la caméra de
selfie elle est juste là c'est une
caméra de 16 mégapixels que brève 2.45
et en plus cette caméra selfie elle vous
permet de déverrouiller grâce à la
reconnaissance faciale en 2D si vous
souhaitez le faire vous pouvez le faire
personnellement je préfère en termes de
sécurité utiliser hop là la biométrie
avec mon capteur d'empreinte digitale
c'est beaucoup plus sécurisé que la
reconnaissance faciale de des mais si
vous voulez utiliser vous pouvez
l'utiliser parce qu'elle est dessus ça
c'est cool voici quelques photos qui ont
été prises avec ce smartphone alors on
va regarder vous allez voir qu'à la
chose qui sont bien il y a des choses
qui sont un peu moins bien fatalement
parce qu'on a pas des très gros capteurs
grosso modo sur le capteur principal de
64 mégapixels le taf est fait bien fait
correct donc ça c'est très très bien dès
qu'on passe sur l'ultra grand-angle
comme on est sur une caméra de 5
mégapixels et bien voyez on perd quand
même vachement piqué il faut savoir
qu'ici sur votre Smartphone vous n'avez
aucune stabilisation optique moi qui a
un tremblement essentiel je suis un vrai
crash test pour les smartphones donc il
y a un moment ça bouge un peu c'est
beaucoup moins bien sur la caméra
principale ça va j'ai aucun problème sur
l'ultra grand-angle de 5 mégapixels
c'est pas fou après je peux venir zoomer
sur ma caméra principale de 64
mégapixels je viens zoomer dans l'image
en fait bon fois deux on peut au-delà on
évite en perd vachement qualité c'est
pas terrible je suis venu chercher dans
différentes situations je me suis mis
sur beaucoup contre jour avec le soleil
en face alors mise à part avoir le Lens
flair qui est dû ici à mon optique et
bien globalement il s'en sort pas trop
mal on reconnaît son bien les arbres ici
également ici donc il y a une bonne
gestion algorithmique ça fonctionne
quand même plutôt pas mal ultra
grand-angle bon pour moi il est un peu
au frais c'est pas terrible on peut
venir zoomer mais on va éviter mais une
fois de plus sur votre capteur principal
le 64 mégapixels le taff est fait c'est
bien c'est joli c'est détaillé le piqué
est bien c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien voilà pour moi c'est
vraiment ça qui va venir être cool après
vous avez un capteur de macro alors les
capteurs de macro si vous me connaissez
vous savez que les deux mégapixels
j'aime pas particulièrement et une fois
de plus on va venir regarder ici c'est
pas terrible et c'est pas très détaillé
donc on va venir éviter alors après je
vais vous donner une petite astuce dans
quelques instants regardez bien la
caméra de selfie elle fait le taf ça se
mégapixel vous voyez bon c'est pas
parfait si vous voulez vraiment venir
chercher la petite bête on va voir
qu'ici vous voyez ça certaines choses on
voit certains détails qui sont créés
numériquement par l'appareil qui vient
rajouter un peu de détails bon ça change
des appareils qui viennent vraiment
lisser les visages donc bon dans l'idée
ça me dérange pas pour autant lorsque je
vais lui mettre des contre-jours et bien
il me sort quand même vachement mon
visage donc ça c'est bien pareil là j'ai
un peu le chercher dans ces
retranchements et il s'en sort bien vous
voyez même avec un beau contre jouable
le soleil derrière ils s'en sort
vachement bien le résultat est très
correct et une fois de plus dans cette
gamme de prix je trouve que le taf est
vraiment bien fait donc là-dessus j'ai
absolument rien à lui dire ça c'est de
la macro je voulais vraiment vous
montrer c'est une astuce que je vous
donne en fait lorsque vous avez un
capteur de mégapixels qui est pas
complètement fou et vous avez un bon
capteur au niveau ici vous voyez vous
avez un 64 mégapixels qui fait le taf et
bien au lieu de faire des photos en
maquereau vous allez galérer des fois à
trouver le bon moment le bon point ça
bouge c'est pas terrible voilà on galère
un petit peu oui j'ai un peu de mal et
bien vous venez prendre votre capteur de
64 mégapixels et vous venez zoomer pas
trop en X 2 vous vous rapprochez et vous
arrivez à trouver un truc qui seront
beaucoup plus jolis vous aurez bien
meilleur définition vous voyez là par
exemple ici je trouve ça beaucoup plus
joli de prendre cette photo comme ça
plutôt qu'avec la macro regardez je vous
montre l'équivalent macro c'est beaucoup
plus terne on a moins de détails et
c'est beaucoup moins joli regardez là
tout de suite c'est quand même
nous fera du très grand temps mais il
faut vraiment se reculer dans la
possibilité qui est pas un bout de
falaise Zahia avec vous ce qui est pas
de tomber dans le vide mais voyez ça
aide vachement et ça c'est vraiment une
astuce que je vous recommande
l'expérience logiciel c'est Magic US 6.1
qui est basé sur un Android 12 pas
Android 13 on est bien sur Android 12
ici alors Magic QI 6.1 c'est pas mal moi
j'aime bien l'expérience c'est assez
correct vous voyez cette petite astuce
là que vous allez avoir lorsque vous
avez des icônes sur Magic QI et bien
avec un petit trait en dessous je sais
pas si vous voyez sur la galerie bien
vous pouvez venir hop vous spoilez vers
le haut et vous avez une petite
information là c'est pareil sur l'agenda
j'en ai un hop là je souhaite je vois
j'ai quelques informations ici
l'appareil sur l'horloge je peux le
faire hop je sois et bien j'ai mon
horloge un peu plus grand sur le
bloc-notes hop PAF bon bah j'ai aucune
note donc ça c'est vrai il y a plein de
petites astuces plein de petit détail
qui sont très chouettes à venir
connaitre ici sur Magic QI alors moi je
le trouve pas mal il y a deux trois
trucs qui sont un peu à venir améliorer
en fait ils sont perfectibles je vous
montre notamment ici ça c'est vraiment
du point de détail mais lorsque vous
mettre sécurité et urgence et là vous
avez sécurité vous dites en fait je
comprends pas il y a deux fois sécurité
bon voilà il faut comprendre un petit
peu le fonctionnement c'est du petit
point de détail mais bon globalement le
taf est fait vous allez retrouver le
numérique est également vous allez avoir
tous différents comptes qui sont là
toutes les mises à jour vous allez
retrouver en bas de l'accessibilité bien
évidemment la gestion de votre batterie
le déverrouillage hop la qui est ici
avec la biométrie je vous ai montré au
niveau de l'affichage c'est très cool
vous avez également votre écran
d'accueil avec différents thèmes vous
allez pouvoir venir mettre ici donc
c'est complet ça marche bien vous allez
pouvoir activer regarder le lien avec
Windows qui est très bien ici avec votre
PC vous avez Honor chaque vous allez
pouvoir venir activer les captures
l'enregistrement de l'écran le contrôle
d'appareil parce que oui regardez vous
avez de l'infrarouge et on peut venir
utiliser son smartphone en infrarouge
donc ça c'est cool donc voilà ça ça
fonctionne bien l'expérience c'est cool
un autre petit point de détail que
j'aime un peu moyen ici ça pourrait être
perfectible en fait c'est lorsque vous
voulez faire des photos vous voyez vous
êtes comme ça vous appuyez vous changez
vous avez vos menus ça me va bien en
plus c'est très complet j'ai plein de
choses ici je vais avoir différents
modes de prise de photo vous avez de la
Super Macro du HDL panorama timelapse là
où résolution le mode storia le mode
multi vidéo vous allez avoir hop là
regardez la vidéo à l'arrière et la
vidéo à l'avant on va pouvoir venir
changer ici si on le souhaite donc je
trouve ça pas mal je trouve ça assez
malin et une fois de plus sympa donc ils
ont bien bossé sur l'expérience logiciel
il y a un truc à venir la forêt au nord
je vous le dis c'est qu'en fait lorsque
je prends mon smartphone voyez que je
suis comme ça je suis en train
d'enregistrer que je vais venir zoomer
et ben en fait ça se trouve ici et ça
c'est chiant parce que moi je voudrais
faire une main moi je tiens mon
smartphone comme ça et donc là je vais
pouvoir le faire donc là je suis obligé
de venir ici tac j'ai mon ultra grand
temps qui est là et ensuite tag j'ai mon
zoom là et lorsque je vais venir zoomer
en faisant une photo et bien vous voyez
je dois poser mon doigt et en plus le
zoom il est pas à droite parce que je
trouverai logique je me rapproche de
Live je vais zoomer non il est de
l'autre côté donc je dois venir là et là
hop là et là je peux venir zoomer et bon
alors après j'ai pas bien zoomer
énormément parce que le smartphone n'est
pas fou fou pour ça mais je trouve que
d'un point de vue expérience ciel il y a
un truc à venir améliorer donc il y a
pas grand chose qui me fait râler il y a
ces petits points de détails là que je
trouve des fois un peu optimisable
facilement existe on peut faire de
l'optimisation en tout cas pour autant
et ça c'est bien vous pouvez mettre une
double carte SIM à l'intérieur ici pas
d'extension de stockage c'est 128 128
sinon il faut aller dans le Cloud après
comme on est sur un écran OLED et bien
on a du always on display vous avez donc
ici quelques petits affichages je sais
pas ce que ça ne consomme pas énormément
donc ça c'est cool bien évidemment du
NFC et puis c'est un smartphone que vous
pouvez acheter s'il vous intéresse
fatalement on s'en doutera il est
disponible au tarif de 3 79 euros à
partir d'aujourd'hui sur le site de
eyonor allez jeter un coup d’œil une
fois de plus je vous mets un lien en bas
dans la description et d'ailleurs il y a
une offre de lancement à partir du 21
février vous allez avoir au nord band 7
offert d'une valeur de 59,90 €. le Honor
band 7 c'est un bracelet tracker qui
donne l'heure qui fait plein de choses
et qui vous accompagneront dans votre
vie quotidienne notamment pour le sport
et ce qui est génial c'est que vous avez
un écran à molette de 1,47 pouces une
grosse autonomie de deux semaines 96
modes d'entraînement donc pour le sport
franchement il y a de quoi faire un
suivi de l'aspo2 de votre rythme
cardiaque du stress d'ailleurs ça c'est
vachement cool enfin c'est cool le
stress c'est pas cool mais de le suivre
ça c'est bien par contre et en plus
d'avoir votre Honor band 7 offert vous
avez un coupon de 50 euros de remise
avec le code am 5 Kol profitez donc de
l'offre de lancement pour avoir votre
smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions plus avec une montre une
promo bref sur sa vachement bien merci
qui merci au nord Magic 5 like moi je le
trouve intéressant ce smartphone il est
fait pour vous potentiellement si vous
cherchez un smartphone avec une très
grosse autonomie un tarif maîtrisé on se
parle de 379 euros et ça une fois de
plus c'est plutôt pas mal avec un bel
écran qui sera bien pour le multimédia
6,67 pouces avec de la performance il
sera très corail pour venir jouer à des
jeux grâce au sein dragon 695 ça c'est
cool 5G bien évidemment en photo le
capteur de 64 mégapixels fraltaff et
pour moi c'est un très bon rapport
qualité-prix si vous aimez au nord si
vous aimez la marque et si vous aimez
l'écosystème avec des ordinateurs qui
sont cool je monte là parce que j'en ai
un qui est juste là que vous voulez des
montres connectés que vous voulez des
écouteurs au nord que vous voulez allez
que vous êtes déjà dans l'écosystème au
nord et bien le Magic sympa était très
cool voilà donc on continuera à parler
de Honor très bientôt avec le Magic
Sandro qui sera annoncé d'ici quelques
temps on va voir il va arriver ça c'est
chouette on regardera ce qui va arriver
du côté de Honor bien évidemment en 2023
c'est une marque qui se développe
énormément qui a les services Google et
ça c'est chouette donc on en reparle
très bientôt donc d'ici là restez
connectés puis si vous avez des
questions interrogations suggestion ça
se passe en bas dans les commentaires je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
ça